[Musique]
faux
tout là-haut dans l'espace
parmi les étoiles et les galaxies il
existe une étrange petite planète carré
et cette planète s'appelle auguste c'est
ici qu'habitent watou à tous et c'est
trois petits amis comme ils peuvent se
multiplier et se transformer à l'infini
ils voient tous n'ont pas de problème
pour s'amuser
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
regardez et moi tout à tous sans
transformer en planche à roulettes et
ainsi tout le monde peut jouer
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
et c'est comme ça que depuis toujours
ils passent leurs journées
[Musique]
tout allait bien sur cette planète
quand soudain un matin gerin une capsule
spatiale deux doigts ou plutôt 2 west
rhône hot 100 aux commandes
gracieusement la capsule amorce sa désor
[Musique]
mais qu'est ce qui se passe non pas un
mot n'est secret quand dans une machine
à laver là dedans
[Musique]
mais qu'est ce qui se passe qu'est ce
qui se passe dans l'espace
[Musique]
rapidement l'alerté donnée il faut taper
le président alors voilà la commune un
trottoir
[Musique]
ça y est la capsule est dégagé
paris
[Musique]
bien voilà
elle revient vers la tête regardez était
mon panier
[Musique]
ah ah
et c'est ainsi qu'un beau jour watou à
tous est arrivé sur la peur à tous à
tous qui a suivi les capsules spatiales
arrive pour la première fois sur la
terre enfin pour l'instant il en est
encore à découvrir la mer
[Musique]
comme il n'a jamais rencontré deux fois
il décide de les suivre pour les
regarder vivre
[Musique]
quelle étrange petit oiseau
ça va
un peu plus tard au palais présidentiel
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
what what on appelle ce trois petits à
nice
[Musique]
après la réception officielle les deux
astronautes et le président sont salués
par la foule
tiens la famille soir
[Musique]
bah voilà tout on soir au banquet le
comédien celui là
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ils sont amusants c'est cette planète
tout compte fait
[Musique]
allez va faire qu'on ne
et vous le circuit
[Musique]
[Rires]
et qu'est ce que c'est étrange petit
animal oh mon dieu ou à toi toi voler le
credo chien du président
[Musique]
mais non ouattara que vous voulez tout
simplement offrir le crès de chiens à la
famille moi ça c'est gentil
et maintenant le grand jeu les oies toi
tu ouvres sont transformés en quoi
regarder
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et oui les boîtes où va tout se
transforme en pluie
[Musique]
photo
je m'appelle loi tout va tout et je vois
tout à bientôt
[Musique]
il est 7h doucement la ville s'éveille
doucement je crois que j'ai parlé un peu
trop vite
[Musique]
oh là là quelle panique
allez allait dépêcher en dépêchant
[Musique]
l'éviter pêche en dépêchant
avec tout le monde dans la rue
[Musique]
vit-on vite été oublié ta voiture non se
précipita leasing quoi on repart et au
cours à l'école le maître n'aime pas les
retardataires au piquet tous ces gens
qui s'agitent ça donne le tournis
[Musique]
what our à tout prend la place de la
girouette et c'est parti dans l'autre
sens vite toujours plus vite vite
encadré
allez allez des pêcheurs des pêcheurs
[Musique]
et on se dépêche de ça c'est de voir et
on se dépêche de dîner et on se dépêche
d'aller dormir ou heureusement la nuit
c'est plus calme moitié mais je suis au
besoin de revenus dans leurs deux heures
de sommeil en plus
[Musique]
le lendemain matin vite allez c'est
reparti mais selon des puceaux
j ai dit allez les visites accord mais
n'ont rien compris à les retards bonheur
[Musique]
attendu
vous êtes en avance bien tabac soit vous
êtes à l'heure bravo les enfants à
naître marc vient pas
[Musique]
donc voilà la vie beaucoup plus agréable
quand on prend son temps et les soirées
sont plus tard
[Musique]
tiens mais qu'est ce que fait la
girouette d'un jardin ça y est la
famille on a compris
[Musique]
merci à tout va tout grâce à toi le
prenons le temps de vivre
au revoir
[Musique]
ça y est le petit déjeuner servi en
français bien pressé ce matin du moins
en france qui n'attend plus quelque
chose il va te laver les dents ou mais
au fond ce n'est pas ça ça pique la
langue ils ont le tricheur 3
montgaillard tu as quand même te laver
les dents mais maman soit vu que la
france n'était pas servi de savoir ça
dans fm
mon dieu qu'est la laine fo s'était pas
lavé les dents ce matin mais si maman
mais d'ambri mais nous on ne comprend
plus rien
une brosse à dents et dentifrice baby et
oui c'est grâce à vous tous et vous
[Musique]
prend vos mots d'amour votre vaisselle
étincelles ça donne une idée la douane
forme pauvres créé deux chiens oh là là
quelle catastrophe
[Musique]
alphand ne veut pas rentrer comme sa
maman on va te passer un de ces savants
[Musique]
mais qu'est ce que va faire des petits
bateaux est
mais oui la visual france tout
simplement
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
merci à tous à tous et le lendemain
matin c'est bien en france
tu as bien compris tu viens jouer avec
nous la boue c'est chouette
[Musique]
les petits oiseaux à tout se transforme
en gouttes de pluie tandis que d'autres
lancent des savons des gants des tubes
de dentifrice
[Musique]
et finalement c'est sympa de se laver
ni qu'ils aient bousalle france
[Musique]
merci à toi tout revoir
web
rien de tel qu'un peu de gymnastique
garder la forme et un bon bain de vapeur
car cela permet de rester les mains
[Musique]
je
il est en suivant ce régime là vous ne
risque pas de maigrir
résultat au lieu de perdre du poids on
prend des kilos et oui et les
médicaments n'y changeront rien mesdames
[Musique]
et plus elle continue mais sont
incorrigibles ségo cachent les pilules
pour maigrir
j'ai pts le chocolat
[Musique]
espérons qu ailleurs les autres seront
plus raisonnables auxquelles appétit
[Musique]
o les points feraient bien mais arrêtez
mais ça suffit
[Musique]
après avoir mangé tout ça on se sent un
peu lourd
[Musique]
mais ma parole mais dans ce restaurant
aussi les gens mangent trop vous êtes
tous malades il faut faire quelque chose
doit tout va tout
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
commençons par faire disparaître les
pâtisseries
[Musique]
oui et vous goinfrer
regardez vous dans une glace et oui vous
êtes trop énorme à les jetons tout ça ce
qu'il faut c'est une bonne cure
d'amaigrissement bien ses rêves et des
belles vapeur bien chaud
[Musique]
et surtout une alimentation saine et mes
yeux avait commencé pas des carottes ne
trichait pas ne trichait pas ne trichez
pas allez bon appétit et soyez
raisonnable au revoir retour à tous
merci
là
qu'est ce que c'est sale ici oh la la
zone c pas possible sans mais partout ça
colle aux plus anciens voilà des oies
qui marche un canard
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui c'est vrai un brin de toilette tout
frais pas demain le tout oh là là mais
ça n'avance pas et bien sûr les oies
s'énerve qu'elle embouteillages
heureusement what what aux règles la
circulation qui se transforme en feu
rouge stop feux rouges feu vert feu
rouge feu vert feu rouge feu vert feu
rouge feu vert bravo à tous et tous
voila le résultat
[Applaudissements]
un peu plus tard à table avec toute la
famille doit t'on soit tu dois beaucoup
trop au résultat tu marche pas droit
[Musique]
pour votre tournoi au dans ton état tu
ferais mieux de laisser ta voiture tu
sais et attention tu as quoi c'est là
que doit tout à tous
[Musique]
mais les fous mais c'est dangereux on ne
boit pas en conduisant watou à tout
appel les petits voient tout à son
secours
[Musique]
les petits watts où s'alignent le long
de la route de se transforme en barrière
de sécurité
ouf sauvé à 80 ans doivent avoir
quelques ennuis way
aïe aïe aïe tonton soit s'est arrêté
sans mettre ses feux de détresse
heureusement les petits gars tout se
transforme en fait d'être f va bien et
vous vos papiers
ah mais non mais c'est pas possible vos
papiers
attendez je vais vous expliquer je ne
suis pas d'ici je viens de l'espace je
passe mon temps à me prélasser
j'adore danser et m'amuser
mais quand je vois des oies en danger je
suis partout je vole dans tous les sens
pour les sauver
[Musique]
quant à toi ton soit il vaut mieux te
faire accompagner
au revoir à tous à tous et merci
[Musique]
bonjour tonton soir
allez c'est ma tournée
[Musique]
pendant ce temps à la maison on attend
ton doigt pour se mettre à table
oh là là leur qui va brûler
[Musique]
bravo ton doigt
c'est trop tard le rôti et brûlé ah ben
bravo à tous les deux
[Musique]
credo chats n'aiment pas le vin
ah bah vous êtes dans un drôle d'état
[Musique]
bien entendu durant la nuit les deux
alcooliques sont malades et c'est encore
maman soit qui s'occupe de faire venir
le médecin
[Musique]
on les monte
bon
[Musique]
les petits oiseaux atouts pénètre dans
le café attrape les bouteilles bouteille
de vin bien sûr et les vides dans le
caniveau
ils remplissent d'eau et de sirop de
grenadine un autre côté et la maladie de
papa soit quand on voit ne s'arrange pas
pour ça qu'ils ont des hallucinations
l'écoutille watts ou en profite pour
pénétrer dans l'appartement et là ils
répètent la même opération
le lendemain au café mais cette fois
sans entendons soit qu'est ce que tu
aimes faire trop 15 mois au est ce que
tu crois que c'est comme ça que tu va
guérir credo chien boit du vin mais non
souvenez vous c'était de la grenadine at
war est un boni à watou à tous il n'y a
qu'un seul remède la piqûre
et après ça vous vous sentirez mieux
regarder
[Musique]
et attention maintenant il ne faut plus
boire d'alcool
[Musique]
les hallucinations encore mais non vous
êtes presque guérie
oui mais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bravo à toi tout
au revoir et merci déjà une cigarette
si tôt le matin encore une et monsieur
soit tu ne sais pas lire les panneaux
seraient wagon non fumeurs mais voilà il
fait tousser creux de chiens mais c'est
le contrôleur fait quelque chose
wagon fumant
[Musique]
il est temps que tu fasses quelque chose
doit tout béton
[Musique]
[Rires]
à
les petits bateaux à tour se transforme
pompiers allez venez respirer l'air pur
de la campagne
vous en avez besoin que fait-il
ah oui des cigarettes ce pétard tagon
finnair et une cigarette ou c'est vous
qui allez c'est ça
[Musique]
il ne ce soir ne se sent pas très bien
il est en retard
[Musique]
enfin si je vous pardonne guère plus
la leçon a porté et transformer la boîte
et siggers ans plus tard attention par
ce petit oiseau à tous au revoir et
merci
[Musique]
si bien dit monsieur les affaires ont
l'air de marcher que d'argent
[Musique]
tiens c'est nouveau ça on remplace et
parcomètres par des machines à sous
enfin voilà une idée
toi
[Musique]
bonjour de famille soit
pauvre tonton soit tu as tout perdu
[Musique]
au nom tout on doit tout va pas
recommencer
tu sais bien qu'il n'a pas de chance au
jeu
et voilà encore perdu ballack à la
vitalité de la loi pourrait enfin c'est
pas dur pour tout le monde
[Musique]
cayrol
[Applaudissements]
au nom ton soit c'est de la folie
tu as truyen et
[Musique]
tu vois qu est-ce que je t'avais dit tu
n'as plus à sous
[Musique]
ça va promener credo chiens non tonton
soit tout à tout de même pas vendre
credo chien mais il le fait et tout ça
pour aller jouer
[Musique]
oui très beau chien mer et galaga
s'étaient échappés commentaires sa tante
en soi
[Musique]
on voit tout à tous et quelque chose on
a besoin de toi
[Applaudissements]
ouais
allez il faut retrouver credo chez vous
on n'est pas là ils n'ont plus le voilà
[Musique]
tout autant rachète credo chien neurones
en orange et on se voit tout ça veut
racheter crête au chien il n'est plus là
qu'un dixième c'est pas le même
mais s'est pas créé de chiens il est
tombé sur une échelle il a reçu la
peinture menteur voilà credo siens
[Applaudissements]
commençons par supprimer des jeux
d'argent sont insérés moins tentés de
faire des bêtises
quant à toi gros zwar attend un peu
regardé appelé mesdames et messieurs les
jeux sont faits c'est dur de trouver des
places pour se garer
mais c'est interdit hewitt on voit tu
l'as mérité sa contravention
[Musique]
attention à feu rouge
pauvre du chêne et passait travers le
pare-brise deuxième contravention
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
troisième contravention 3 contre avancée
dans la journée ça coûte cher
[Musique]
chacun son tour chaque instant
que se passe-t-il une attaque de banque
[Musique]
bravo tu vois tu es courageux
qu'est-ce qui est limité
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
voilà la tente on est pris en otage
[Musique]
pauvre tonton soit
à touba tous souffle du gaz hilarant
résultat 80 ans
[Rires]
merci au revoir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mesdames et messieurs bonsoir nous
sommes en direct du stade pour inciter à
la grande finale de football qui va
opposer l'équipe des huits à l'équipe
des oies les tribunes son comble envahi
par une foule sympathique de supporter
les as en pots et les autres
naturellement son compte
du calme et on sera ducale
[Applaudissements]
le coup d'envoi est donné un tueur
magnifique
une nouvelle tête ah non les mêmes faits
les mains tir avec le pied en fait une
tête ne joue pas avec les mains
et c'est reparti gageois son bar
rapidement balle au pied il est fauché
par un adversaire
[Applaudissements]
arbitre a eu raison de siffler on ne
doit pas faire de croche-pied
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le coup franc est tiré
[Applaudissements]
mais la balle est reprise par l'équipe
10 oies et aux messieurs du calme
ce n'est pas un match de boxe intentions
du calme
[Applaudissements]
et ça dégénère aussi dans les tribunes
quelle bagarre
[Applaudissements]
et fidèlement ses crédos chien qui prend
la balle pendant ce temps dans les
tribunes ça ne s'arrange pas oui
décidément ce n'est plus du football
c'est de la course à pied
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les petits bois tous fait un peu de
ménage
[Applaudissements]
ewa tour mais la balle au milieu
et avant le match écoutez wattmètre pas
demain pas de croche pied pas d'un coup
de poing
[Applaudissements]
deuxième mi temps
et on après cris des chiens pour un
ballot
[Applaudissements]
faute puisqu'ils n'ont rien compris un
petit bateau va prendre la place du
ballon
[Applaudissements]
et voilà ça peut apprendre à tricher
on ne touche pas la balle avec les mains
[Applaudissements]
allez maintenant c'est reparti très
sérieusement
une belle tête au fantastique arrêté à
temps et match nul égalité zéro partout
l'arbitré siffle la fin du match c'est
le délit avant les faits
et ces boîtes ou à tous qui a gagné
bravo à tous à tous au revoir et merci
[Musique]
tout en joie va faire des courses ou
hypermarchés ni à gauche c'est ce qu'il
ne faut pas anniversaire de ma soeur
[Musique]
c'est un bouquin de vie profitons-en
pour acheter une petite bouteille droit
de grâce
qu'est ce qu'il raconte à nos gros clubs
tenez c'est ça qu'est ce qu'il raconte
une seconde et monsieur l'agent mais ces
messieurs qui ont quelque chose à vous
dire youpi c'est l'anniversaire de maman
ou papa tu pour attendre que d'autres
sont servis
[Musique]
vite on va l'essayer tour suite
et voyons un peu au loin c'est écrit en
japonais
attendez laissez moi faire
[Musique]
oh
vous attendez attendez ça y est je crois
que j'ai compris et tout ça pour faire
des carottes râpées
[Musique]
je
abbas
[Musique]
dakar 2 juin aps honnête mais bougez
plus un petit sourit remercie vivement
vous pourriez me traduire les modes
d'emploi nettement c'est très je tiens
et son gentil six mois poney s'il vous
plaît tout le monde en voiture
[Musique]
maintenant on écoute professeurs
oui
[Musique]
pour mieux vous comprendre
apprenez la main étrangère sayonara
hasta luego de bail au revoir à tous à
tous et merci
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
fait un 360
[Applaudissements]
enfants
[Musique]
en france
en
[Musique]
d'enfants
e
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
où
et
oh